If you found out your dead mother was alive
and deep within the Earth's core,
what would you do?
You will have to journey
to the center of the Earth where everything
and anything will try to kill you.
I'm going to break down the mistakes made,
what you should do and how to beat the abyss
itself in Made in Abyss.
This little girl is about to go
through literal hell in order
to find her mother, Riko.
Here is not your average little girl.
She is a part of a group
called the Red Whistle Orphan Explorers.
They're trained from a young age
to venture down
deep within the Earth's core,
a place known worldwide as the abyss .
Riko has no idea that this unknown
and barely explored
deep hole will cost her everything she loves.
Riko and her friend are searching for lost
relics near the surface of the abyss,
when all of a sudden her friend
gets discovered by a horrifying crimson split
jaw worm that is about to devour her friend
right in front of Riko's eyes.
Riko, looking on in
sheer terror, acts quickly by blowing on her
red whistle to get the absolutely ginormous
worm's attention.
But it's at that moment that she instantly
regrets her decision and gets tail whipped
by the worm down a shaft, only to have to
continue running for her sweet life.
And the monster is gaining on her
and is about to devour her flesh.
When all of a sudden a huge blast
is emitted right in front of Riko's eyes,
causing the worm to fly away.
Well, that's just great.
That's a Crimson Splitjaw worm
that is a type of carnivorous scarlet
red reptile species that lives
mainly in the third layer of the abyss.
The fact that we saw
it here is insane and super rare,
and let's be honest,
there's no way that we can beat this beast
because we're
just twelve years old in pigtails.
But part of this beast diet does
include ancient artifacts and ruins,
and we noticed that that monster ate
that kid's backpack full of treasures
before it tried to attack him.
And we've got a whole buffet
full of artifacts right in our bag.
So if I was Riko, I would gracefully let
our friends get torn to shreds.
Sorry, but that one have left us
out of the woods just yet.
The only way to get rid of this thing
for good would have been
to throw our bag full of artifacts away
from where we are,
while also retaining one or two in our hands.
Just in case the noise of the bag
dropping in the distance would have gone.
The split jaws attention and we as a result
could have circled around the split
of heading back into the cave right near
where our friend was discovered.
Realistically,
we could not have outrun this monster
for long, so our best bet would have been
to hide within that small cave.
Since it is unlikely
that the split jaw could fit through there.
The remaining few artifacts in our hand
could have been used
as a means of distraction
in case the worm caught on to our plants
before we could have reached the cave.
Riko looks around in confusion and notices
burn marks on the nearby trees.
Whatever that mysterious beam
was was something truly powerful
and highly useful if we can get it.
Riko then notices a pendant,
but not before she spots a young boy
near her age, passed out nearby
with his hands glowing , bright red.
Riko sees that this boy is nothing
short of extraordinary and discovers
that he's not a boy at all, but a robot.
Riko wonders, When in the hell did this
strange robot come from?
Back at the orphanage that Riko lives in,
she begs her climbing teacher to let her go
further into the abyss, wanting to catch up
with her mother, who disappeared years back.
Somewhere within the abyss.
But she doesn't realize that she'll soon
get everything that she ever wanted
and much more.
Later, Riko and her friends
finally managed to wake up the robot boy,
who doesn't even remember that he is a robot,
nor what his special powers are
and who cannot even remember
where he came from.
Riko ends up calling him Reg and begins
showing him around the town, suspecting
that he came from within the abyss
since she found him in it.
Over time, she and her friends secretly
make him a part of the orphanage,
and he learns to live the ways of red
whistle explorers
until one fateful day
changes everything for him and Riko.
A lift(elevator) comes floating up
out of the abyss, and out comes trusted
family friend of Riko called Beard Guy,
who announces that they found the white
whistle of the town's top explorer,
who turns out to belong to Riko's long lost
mother.
The town celebrates
the return of Riko's mother's whistle,
and a big ceremony is given in her honor.
This is where Riko finds out
that she was born from within the abyss
and that her bad eyesight and glasses are
a direct result of the curse of the abyss.
Since there is nothing actually medically
wrong with her eyesight,
Riko also finds out that her mother went
on a long, treacherous journey to the center
of the abyss, resulting in every one of her
teammates dying except for one person.
All the while being pregnant and giving birth
down in the abyss, bringing Riko
back up as a baby from the depths
of the abyss in a curse repelling vessel.
Riko's teacher over here
also says that ascending from the fourth
layer of the abyss is unbearable
even for adults, with Riko herself
only making it back alive as a baby.
Thanks to the vessel, her mother and the one
surviving member of her squad put her in.
OK, this is insane.
If I was Riko, I'd focus less of my time
on climbing and more time on studying
the myths and legends and history
associated with the curse of the Abyss.
Because if my eyesight
was affected enough by the curse
to cause an eyesight impediment for life,
then I personally want to know if the curse
gave or took anything else from me
and I would use everything that I can from
all known realms of science or otherwise.
I'd also ask around
if anyone has ever looked into formulating
a suit made of the materials that occurs.
Repelling vessel is made of because it's
clear that in order to go into the abyss,
we're going to need some help.
And right now, the only thing they gave us
an edge over anyone else is the fact that
we have a strange artifact from the abyss
itself, that robot boy that we met Reg.
I'd also get some help from some trusted,
knowledgeable friends
and anyone that we can find to begin
examining Reg ASAP.
Because if Reg came from the abyss,
that means he must know how to handle it
subconsciously or otherwise.
Later, Riko is given permission to review
the lost contents found within her mother's
belongings, where inside she sees in-depth
guides on the various undiscovered relics
and animals found deep within the cave.
And it's here that she sees a drawing
that looks just like the robot kid Reg.
And that's when Riko discovers
something insane.
She finds a note from her mother saying
that she'll be at the bottom of the abyss
waiting.
Riko then loses her shit
because obviously mom's calling and plans
to go find her mother, who now she thinks
is actually alive and calling for her.
Riko prepares for the most dangerous and
terrifying journey that she will ever take
and is warned by her high ranking peers
that this journey to the bottom of the abyss
is too dangerous to go.
Riko decides to go
anyway, and Reg also agrees to go with her,
wanting to go down with her to find out
just exactly where he comes from and claiming
that he will protect Riko with his life.
Riko's classmates
then plan out the route with this class's guy
bringing out a map of the abyss
a six layer, two nether world, which shows
everything of the abyss that has up until now
been mapped out, with the first layer
being 15 hundred meters down, which is where
they'll encounter terrifying beasts
from the second layer coming up to greet them
as they themselves come looking for prey.
The second layer will be
when the strain of ascending
is said to become too difficult
for most people to bear and is past the limit
where any help from the surface will be sent.
Treating the second layer and everything else
past that as a suicide mission,
the end of the second layer will be
when the immense unstable air currents
and savage monsters of unknown
origin will begin to appear.
The third layer will possess
an immense vertical cliff over 4000 meters,
which they'll need to traverse,
with the fourth layer being only meant
for high ranking black and white wistful
explorers 7000 meters below the fifth layer
known as the sea of corpses
being white whistle exclusive territory
with less than five white whistle explorers
ever returning from those depths,
and finally, the sixth layer from which
no white whistle has ever returned from.
That is where true
terror will await them in the abyss.
OK, first off, I like fame and glory
as much as the next girl.
But the fact that you're willing
to go down there
unprepared just off of an old
note from your mother is so stupid.
We have no idea when this note was made.
So first I'd make a case for us to begin
examining the note and ink from the paper.
It was written on the chemical analysis
of writing and printing eggs
and matching them together
can be invaluable when trying to prove
whether a document is fraudulent or not.
And in this case, I wouldn't risk my life
for my mother unless someone can prove to me
beyond a shadow of a doubt
that it was written by my mother and written
by her recently, and we can do this
by the process of ink dating.
Ink dating is a highly specialized
forensic examination to determine
the age of the ink and can be formulated
to identify a specific
manufacturer to ascertain the first date
of commercial availability.
And the chemical solvents
within the ink that evaporate over time
can be found and traced through a technique
known as gas chromatography
and or mass spectrometry to determine
if the written document was created
within a specific period of time.
And if this puny little town
didn't have access to such things,
then I began sending that bad boy overseas
to a forensic laboratory first,
because you heard
what awaits us down in the abyss?
Certain doom.
So we need to make sure that we don't
go down there purely on a whim or a hunch
because I love my mom,
but I don't know if I love her that much.
The big day of their horrifying adventure
has now come,
and the duo sneaks past everyone and finds
another way down into the abyss .
They say their goodbyes to their friends
and descend down into the blackened
depths below, and this is where all the fun
is about to begin.
Riko and Reg reached the first layer,
but get lost along the way,
with the depth gauge indicating
that they are 820 meters below sea level.
Riko then runs off to get a better vantage
point,
witnessing the first layer of the abyss
and all of its terrifying glory.
Riko thinks this means that at this speed,
they'll make it to the bottom of the abyss
and no time at all.
Reg and Riko
stopped to make breakfast for the day,
while Reg gives Riko an envelope, it's
her mother's sealed letters.
Riko grabs a red slip from the book
written in her mother's handwriting, saying,
I'll depart at dawn to come capture you.
This freaks Riko out as she thinks
they're running late to meet her mother,
and because of this,
they quickly clear out and begin to descend
even further down into the abyss.
But that's when they run into a silk fang.
Reg quickly shoots his robotic arm
at the spider as they make a jump for it,
barely escaping with their lives.
This is a silk fang,
a very common large insect
found within the first layer of the abyss.
This bad boy is known for paralyzing poison
that it spits from its mouth.
Reg did well, but failed to spot the warning
signs earlier that could have prevented
such a thing
from ever happening to begin with.
These creatures are territorial, after all,
and unlike the Splitjaw worm,
they won't attack you
unless you enter their territory.
Riko and Reg should have noticed the warning
signs around them in the form of passing
through a ten meter dome shaped territory,
which marks the zone where a silk fang
would be present to begin with.
This creature rarely,
if ever, leaves its dome, and frankly,
they could have completely ignored
stepping into their territory to begin with
if they just kept a better lookout,
then descending willy nilly, not knowing
what's happening.
Riko and Reg head further in, but Riko
is already feeling the effects of the harsh
abyss, feeling lethargic and slightly weak
as they march further on into the depths.
Riko and Reg then take a break,
but that's when they hear a distinct noise
coming from within the bushes.
It could be a search party that's after them,
so the door runs off at full speed, knowing
that if they are caught,
they will be forced to ascend back up
to the top and away from Riko's mother.
But that's when a huge, burly man
plunges down right in front of them.
It's bearded guy, but luckily for them, he's
not there to capture them.
Thanks to Riko's friends,
they managed to convince bearded guy
to come see them off
before they reached the second layer.
He then gives Riko some supplies, such
as food and a vaccine vial, meant to help
protect her from the effects of the abyss
the further down she goes.
He also tells them
of the white whistle, who helped Riko's mom
bring Riko to the surface as a baby.
Oh, then the immoveable, an expert white
whistle explorer who is active deep
within the depths of the abyss bearded guy
then bids them farewell, and Riko
and Reg descend further into the mysterious
depths of this never ending void.
OK, this is insanely stupid.
They shouldn't have just let their only aid
leave them so soon.
Despite this guy looking like Harry Potter
Shaggy uncle who knows everything
and also knowing everything about this place,
and he's a black whistle explorer,
which is the second most experienced position
besides Expert Mountaineer White Whistle.
I would have done everything I can to build
him tighter to us than a Wellington dinner
because this piece of shit
isn't leaving my sight.
Now, as rookie
climbers, we have already studied
the theory of the abyss and all it contains.
But practical experience
is a whole different thing than just a mere
theory, and beard guy is ripe with practical
advice and wisdom that he can give to us.
Remember, we're just a couple of snotty
twelve year olds. We don't know shit.
first off,
I want more information about this Ozen
the immovable character,
and if she is someone I need to worry about,
I'd also ask more about the third
and fifth layers of the abyss
because the fourth layer
will contain that 4000 meter vertical cliff,
and the fifth will only be where
a few whistles have ever returned from .
This will make scaling down
such areas exponentially more difficult
compared to the second layer.
Riko and Ray are still taking this journey
way too carefully, and this will cost them
the scenery changes
as the duo descends further,
reaching an eerie bit of grassland
surrounded by a sinister looking forest,
they just reach the second layer
of the abyss .
Riko jumps up and down in excitement,
while Reg looks more concerned
knowing the harsh realities of the situation.
After this point, no one will come for them.
They will be all alone.
Riko and Reg decide to head to the seeker
camp located near there,
but is at this moment that they hear a voice
and it's crying out for help.
They run at full speed, getting closer to
the pleas
of what seems to be someone in trouble.
But in the abyss, nothing is as it seems
they come across the source of the cries
for help, which turns out to be coming
from a strange creature of some sort
as it feeds on the corpse of a dead
cave raider.
It's a corpse sweeper,
and Reg prepares to kill it.
But Reko knows something is up
and thinks it's a trap, and she's right.
As another corpse, Weaver
comes diving down straight for Reko,
plucking her from the surface
and ascending high up into the sky.
Reg tries to act fast and aim
his robotic arm,
but it's deflected by another corpse weeper.
He tries again, but the same thing happens.
These creatures know his every move,
and they attack Reg with full force
striking terror
at the very heart of his robotic soul.
He's running out of time.
He decides to turn on his massive beam gun,
the same weapon that saved Riko
at the very beginning.
Knowing that if he misses
his weapon could kill Riko, Reg unleashes
the full force of his mighty unknown powers
as he fires his raging blast.
Straight at the corpse weeper
lighting up the sky, fiery red,
forcing all the creatures to fly away
and freeing Riko with Reg having to save her
before she comes crashing down.
That's my good
weebs is a very large bird that lives
within the second layer of the abyss.
And this is why children aren't
allowed to go down to these areas
because Riko and Reg
were way too naive for their own good,
rushing off to the cries of help
without any thought put behind it first.
If we noticed during the second or third cry
from the mysterious voice
right before they found the source,
the sound of the cries for help sounded
almost raspy, with almost alien
like inflection in the sound of the voice.
Much like the predator species,
when it tries to mimic its prey at first
glimpse of the corpse weeper,
Riko and Reg should have considered
this person to be already dead,
even if he wasn't.
Because Riko is familiar
with what this species is
and should have known
from the very first sighting that
this species of bird always hunts in packs,
especially during breeding season,
and often drives prey towards their colony
to hunt them to gather upon first glance.
Riko and Reg should have run away from them
using the cover of trees as a defense against
being picked off by these corpse sweepers
from the air.
Worst case, I would have stayed
under the cover of forest and trees, forcing
any nearby corpse weavers
to try and attack me within close proximity
and from the ground.
This way, Reg could have subdued their wings
from close range, and Riko could have aided
in blinding them.
The corpse sweepers reliance on their superb
spatial awareness was the only weak point
that we could have realistically harmed
if we got them close enough to us first.
Yet again, Riko is overzealous with joy
and naive as to the harsh realities of
the abyss, but tells Reg that she can help
Reg train to use his powers more effectively.
But suddenly, a wave of sleepiness
comes over him, forcing him to pass out.
Reg suddenly wakes up
after a terrifying dream, finding out that
he's been asleep for two hours
and that Riko has lost her notebook.
The duo continues on with their journey
reaching further into the dark
entrance, ways into the abyss,
finally reaching the point where everything
and the abyss is upside down.
Even the waterfalls with crazy winds
forcing Reg to not use his grappling hand
looks like they're going to have to start
climbing the normal way from here on out.
No more shortcuts for them.
The two then discover strange alien
like monkeys who throw things at them,
which force them to run by the harsh
winds caused them to crash hard.
Looks like this journey is going to be a lot
harder than they thought.
They continue on
and eventually reach the Seeker Camp, a place
where the force field of the abyss is weaker
and the atmosphere is not as violent.
The Seeker Camp has a telescope to monitor
any and all activity around the area.
Riko and Reg approached the sinister
looking camp
sitting in the midst of all the trees,
but the lift is not working, so Reg shoots
his retractable hands to send them up,
but is suddenly grabbed by a pair of black
gloved hands.
But these hands are no ordinary hands.
They belong to the famous white
whistle Ozen, the immovable
sending the left down the shaft.
The duo then heads up,
not knowing what awaits them
at the top of this scary looking place.
Here they meet one of the most famous white
whistles of all time, and she recognizes
who Riko is.
Ozen the immovable towers over the two kids
and invites them into her place.
Riko then shows Ozen her mother's note,
telling her
that this is the reason they came here.
But Ozen then just walks away,
saying that they can rest here for a while
and she leaves the room.
The gang get some rest
and meets up with Ozen's assistant blue
haired girl who shows them around the place.
But it is here that Ozen meets them again
and reveals that the note with Riko's
mother's handwriting is not actually written
by her mother always entails.
Recall that her journey is over
and that her mother is actually dead, as
is evident by her white whistle.
To top off the shocking news, Ozen says
that she's also found Riko's mother's letters
at her gravesite deep below the abyss,
meaning that Riko's mother is actually dead.
What did I tell you?
Did not say that I was skeptical
that Riko's Mother's handwriting was real.
Come on now.
If I'm Riko, I would believe
I was from the get-go and call it quits
right here and now, and then go on a sweet
relic hunt before heading back up to my town.
We have no idea what's further down below
other than near-certain death.
I'd also beg Ozen
to give us free training lessons
and start by inspecting Reg thoroughly.
He is probably the most powerful
being in this world, and up until now,
Riko has not spent much time in figuring out
just what he is truly capable of.
She needs to stop treating him like a friend
and more like a lethal weapon.
The max depth of the abyss that we know of
is between 13,000 to 15,000 meters deep.
In comparison to the tallest mountain
in our world, Mount Everest is 8849 meters.
This dang
hole is bigger in size than Mount Everest.
If our mother was alive, I'm pretty sure
she would want us to save ourselves,
especially if we're a little girl
that's about to risk our lives on a hunch.
Ozen then leads the shocked duo into her
chambers, where they see this
massive, wondrous white box a relic so unique
that.
It's not even in the relic guidebook,
one that Riko's mother brought along.
It's the curse rappelling vessel.
It's a relic designed to prevent
any of the side effects that one would get
if they ascended from the abyss.
It was made to help creatures who are unable
to make the trip back to the surface.
But Ozen says that the relic also did
something else amazing that whatever contents
were placed inside the box would begin
to be embellished with life.
Riko then finds out
that she was born stillborn and that it was
only when her corpse was placed
inside the relic that she came back to life.
Ozen also tells Riko in a twist
that she actually despises her and tells her
that she is
nothing but a walking corpse,
and that's when Reg
has had enough of her shit and confronts her.
But that's when he made the biggest mistake,
because Ozen is more God than mortal,
and she's about to destroy both of them.
She's way stronger than rogue by far,
and she challenges him to the death,
and Egg does his best
but is no match for Odin's terror.
Riko comes running to raise safety,
but is slapped unconscious.
OK, this did not work out so good for them.
Ozen is the top white whistle.
There is and is over half a century old,
and there's no way that we can beat
her being left to die in the abyss.
Years ago, Hosein received one
and eventually collected 120,000 men pins
artifacts embedded into her skin, which are
first grade artifacts found within the abyss,
which can enhance the user's strength
and longevity tenfold with just a single pen.
This is the source of her power
and durability and the reason
that we can't beat her as easily as we think.
If I was rec,
I'd give up fighting this towering giant lady
who could step on us any day and retreat,
but not for good.
I'd argue that the only way to beat her
would be the Hail Mary of a long shot to
go find two more thousand man pens near
the bottom of the fifth layer by visiting
the only station where white whistles
can venture to within the fifth layer.
A forward operating base known as Idle
Front here, I think we'd have our best bet
in finding more thousand men pens to collect
first before coming back to destroy this
towering feminine monstrosity.
Or, as noted by Reg's Energy Beam, we could
try using that as a last ditch attempt.
But this could only work
if we found some sort of way to surprise Ozen
when she would be least prepared
as long as she doesn't
know what powers were capable of just yet.
So a surprise attack at a later
date may be our only option.
As for Riko, being stuck
there should be fine.
She'll be fine.
Reg aims his terrifying energy gun at Ozen,
preparing to destroy her here and now.
But Ozen deflects the rabies,
causing Reg to think fast and emit upward,
blowing a hole in the wall.
Reg battles her with all
his might blow after blow, but it's no use.
Rig passes out again
and wakes up to a crying Riko, along with
some cave raiders who came in after blue
haired girl called them in for help.
In a shocking twist,
turns out to be all a twisted
test done by Ozen to test their strength
in order to see if they're prepared
for the harsh
terrain in the abyss
that they'll soon encounter.
Reg also finds out from Ozen
that he passes out
every time he uses his laser beam gun
for exactly two hours
and that he's almost indestructible,
according to Ozen,
and then reveals that the grave where Riko's
mother is buried is actually empty and says
that Rikos mother is still down there,
and this time she's not messing with that.
Later, Ozen prepares to whip these kids
into shape and leaves them out in the forest,
saying that for ten days in the harsh
wilderness, they'll be forced to survive.
To show owes them that they've got
what it takes to handle the next few layers,
then the abyss.
Reg and Riko get to work building a fire
and tent and learn the ways of how to survive
the harsh wilderness of the abyss.
During this process,
Ozen and her team keep an eye on them,
learning their weaknesses and strengths.
Riko and Reg soon learn the ways of this
terrifying forest, even managing to capture
this ghastly looking jungle beast for dinner
with some tricks and some traps,
learning and preparing for the harsh layers
of the abyss that they have yet to face down.
Below the ten days finally pass as Riko
and Reg make it back to Odin's camp,
all withered and battered
by their adventures in the forest.
They finally made it.
Ozen then welcomes them back with a dinner
and reveals to them how the passage of time
works differently.
The deeper in the abyss
you go with months on the surface
equating to mere weeks or even days
deep within the abyss.
This means that Riko is not crazy
and that her mother could actually be alive.
But Ozen says to watch out for the other
white
whistles on the fifth layer of the abyss,
the deepest layer that humans
are currently capable of going to,
including the reckless and pure evil
white whistle known as the sovereign of Dawn
Bond Drood the novel.
But Ozen thinks that Riko's mothers
note is a fake and not actually written
by Riko's mother due to the penmanship
being overly large and crooked.
OK, we've known for a while
now that our mothers know it could be a fake,
but since there's no basis to determine
what we're holding is indeed real or not.
But Ozen is onto something here.
The study of handwriting analysis is a way
in which a person's fine motor
skills can leave.
Clues about the author's identity based on
a set of predetermined characteristics,
which is what forensic experts routinely do,
they have to distinguish between style
characteristics
and individual characteristics, which takes
a lot of training with people at max sharing
maybe one or two similar characteristics.
But the possibility of sharing up to 20 to 30
characteristics is virtually impossible.
This is the reason why no one's handwriting
is exactly the same and can be identified
by looking for a wide array
of individual traits
from letter form, including the curves
slants, the proportional size of the letters
to line form, including how smooth and dark
the lines are indicating pressure
applied to formatting, including the spacing
between letters and words and the margins.
A writer leaves empty on a page,
and Ozen could tell
all of this from a simple glance
because if Ozen was with Riko's mother
for any significant length of time,
then she probably could have been able
to tell Riko's mother's handwriting
just what in the world is waiting
at the bottom of the netherworld with Riko's
mother always then wanders, and
this is exactly what Riko aims to find out.
Ozen gives them an ax weapon
that belonged to Riko's mother, and Ozen
heads them off down into the third layer.
Riko and Reg reach an empty, gaping chasm
filled with horrifying winged beasts known
as Madoka Jacks, while they look for a way
to descend down even further.
Reg then grapples another entrance
with his hook hands as he descends with Riko.
But then here's something terrifying
something is hunting for them.
Looks one more time
towards the source of the sound before
Riko calls him to explore the cave further
with these fur balls after which they reach
an abandoned ship
stuck in between the rocks and explore it
before Riko steps in something sinister,
something that frightens her to her core
as she looks
more closely to see skeleton remains
just then a madoka jack.
Or, let's say,
MJ attacks them before Reg saves Riko.
This is it.
Needs to act fast, but is terrified
of passing out after using his blaster rig.
Thinks again if he wants to use it
while this monster comes for their flesh.
This bad boy means serious business
and catches their prey while airborne.
Usually honestly, Riko
should have seen the signs or we should have,
say, smelt the signs
because she stepped in their poop.
These creatures aren't exactly
the most sanitary of creatures to begin with,
and their nests are usually accompanied
by nearby feces that surround the area.
And we know from Ozen
that Reg is indestructible.
But realistically, his winning bet
is that energy beam gun of his.
So I'd say that why don't we go
balls to the wall and jump inside MJ's mouth,
sliding down its esophagus and getting cozy
from inside the monster itself?
Insane thought I know, but
Ozen told us that he's indestructible
and we can't afford to miss
because hello, everybody knows
the insides of a monster are way softer.
We hope,
and we know with the near certainty
that the monster's bowels
won't dissolve us in the acid in the process.
Problem solved.
Just then, Reg aims his hand and hopes to God
that he doesn't
miss and fires his ray beam blaster,
decapitating the beast right there.
Reg then tells Riko to hide
and to be on alert, since Reg knows that he's
about to pass out, and Riko prepares herself
to take on the horse without Reg.
But just then, another split jaw worm
finds them, which forces the duo
to run for their life and turns out
that it has injuries on its body.
Exactly where Reg shot it earlier, meaning
that this is the same monster from earlier
and that it's been following them.
They barely escaped with their lives,
managing to squeeze through a small shaft
just as Reg finally passes out,
forcing Riko to be all alone.
But Riko being young
and ill equipped for these depths,
she decides to explore the cave even further,
taking an unconscious Reg with her
exploring the various ventricular shafts
that this menacing cave presents to her.
But then she suddenly smells something sweet.
It's the smell of fruit,
and her little tummy is rumbling.
Riko runs
to trace the source of this smell, but
not before she falls right into this hole.
But it's no ordinary hole.
It's filled with animal fur ball corpses,
and it's not a hole, but a stomach.
They're inside Amakagame, and its fruit
smell was a trap to lure the fur balls in.
And now it has Riko.
But Riko thinks fast and whips out her knife,
puncturing a hole right
through this beast's belly,
and they quickly expel
the creature's innards and are now covered
in the scent of fresh fruit.
But that's bad news bears,
because Riko gets up and looks around her
and sees nothing but fur balls,
and they're hungry because she smells
just like their favorite fruit.
So Riko runs for her little life
tugging, unconscious Reg along with all
her might as she falls and crawls her
way out of that horrifying situation.
But just then, another splayed
jaw worm pops up right in front of them,
ready to eat their young flesh.
So Riko quickly hands Reg, who is now wide
awake a weapon, and he charges at the worm
and defeats it, causing them to barely
get out of another life and death situation.
The duo exhausted, then head off
and finally get one step closer
to reaching the bottom of the abyss.
And now they finally reach the fourth layer.
They take refuge in what appears to be a tree
surrounded by countless pools of water
covered by steam, but then Reg senses
something in the atmosphere.
Something is watching them, Riko suggests.
They get the heck out of there,
but that's when they see it
the most horrifying monster
that they've ever encountered.
And or piercer Riko and Reg Stand paralyzed
in fear, and Riko mentions that they need
to run armed with quills that can pierce
through steel and laced with poison.
There's no way that they can fight this orb
piercer head on.
Reg grabs Riko and runs, but this beast is
too quick for them and slices their backpack.
They're going to need a new plan.
Turns out their only weapon given by Ozen
was dropped right next to the or piercer.
The Beast then charges at them again,
while Riko hands Reg, an umbrella like shield
defending themselves at the last moment
until something goes horribly wrong.
It's Riko and she's been stabbed.
She then collapses as the poison takes
hold of her and is trembling in pain.
Reg now knows that
he truly can't beat this beast.
Not yet.
And so he whips out
his grappling hook and bolts out of there
with Riko before the monster can get them.
Jeez, this is an orb, a piercer.
These creatures are herbivores by nature,
but are fiercely territorial
and defensive over their territory.
A single or piercer has taken the lives
of over 100 Black
Whistle's over the years,
and Reg royally underestimated this beast.
Now this thing has only one weakness,
and that is its face
with this organ being part of their face
that senses the force field of the abyss.
But they made the mistake
in trying to run from the get go,
as it's clear from the ability
to sense movement
that this beast knew our movements
from the beginning.
And because of this, Raegan Riko lost their
only weapon, their Blaze Reaper pickax
that Ozen gave to them instead of running Reg
should have wrapped his first hand around
Riko and had her jump off the platform
and hang to stay out of harm's way
and then should have waited for the orb
piercing to charge at him.
Remember,
he's likely darn near indestructible.
Therefore, he could have used this orbs
piercer momentum to his advantage,
waiting for that beast to charge at him
before planting his pickax
deep into its organs
near its face and killing it then in there.
But Reg is not out of the woods just yet
because Riko's
arm has grown twice in size
and she is dying fast .
She begs Reg to amputate her arm,
but he gets scared.
If he doesn't do this, she will die.
Reg finally gets some robotic balls
and whips out his knife and begins
doing the most horrifying
and necessary thing he's ever done.
Cutting off the arm of a little girl, Riko
then suddenly passes out
and it looks like she's not breathing,
causing Reg to freak out.
Hard.
But that's when he sees someone
a weird, fluffy looking creature
named Nanachi, who offers to help them out.
Reg doesn't trust her fully,
but he has no choice and begins
to follow this strange creature
back to her house at her place.
We then find out that Nanachi is a hollow,
and over the course of the next few
days, Nanachi.
She helps restore Riko back to health,
and they in the process also meet
a strange creature who is also a hollow
a person who was once a human who ascended
from the six layer long ago, causing them
to lose their humanity and turn into a beast.
This is what could happen to Riko
if they aren't careful down there now.
Nanachi also shows Reg some new tricks
and helps him
go back to fight the monster
that nearly killed a Riko the orb piercer.
And they intervene
right before this terrifying monster
is about to kill this lost explorer.
And so Reg with the help of Nanachi,
she manages to grab a horde of this beast
organs while shooting his grappling hooks
to tie the beast up.
And Reg obliterates
this beast with the full force of his energy
being causing a massive orb of light
to spawn right in front of them,
followed by an explosion
and Nanachi's eyes widened in shock and awe.
Now he did well.
We pretty much suggested
just changing it up a little
by using his blaster,
but we could have been yet again
a little more clean on our execution
with some bait.
Now, I'm not saying that we should have used
Riko as bait.
We shouldn't use Riko as bait.
However, she's pretty much already dead
by ignoring this puny human del.
He found a new companion better
equipped to help us on a journey,
who is also not a tiny eight year
old girl with glasses.
Yes, this would be heartless,
but her death would be a noble one,
and we could use her half conscious corpse
as bait against the or piercer
by laying her down
within the orb piercer territory
and waiting for the Beast
to show up and kill Riko.
Then we could come up from behind
and take it down with our blaster.
Worst case, we'd mess pass out,
and the Orb Monster would try
to crush our unconscious body for two hours
until we awaken yet again for round two.
After seeing Reg's massive energy weapon,
she has one favor to ask him,
and that is to kill her beloved.
Hello friend, this hollow beast.
However, Reg's mouth drops
open at this shocking request.
We then also find out about Nanachi
she's passed
and that she and this hollow beast
friend of hers are part of an experiment
conducted
by the twisted white whistle
sovereign of Dawn Bond Rudd.
The novel caused by experiments
in finding out what.
Happens when someone comes into contact
with the curse of the abyss
after quickly ascending from the sixth layer,
and that this experiment caused
now that his beloved
best friend to lose her humanity
and become this indestructible
beast and force Nanachi to change her form
into what we see now.
Reg then thinks that she's alive
due to her response and being called by name,
but Nanachi says that it's just
a brain reflex and that her hollow friend
actually longs to die.
But due to her indestructible skin cannot die
no matter how hard Nanachi tries.
But she thinks that Reg's energy beam is
the only thing that has the power to do it.
If Reg has the will,
the days pass as Riko heals more.
And finally, Reg prepares to kill, admonishes
best friend, blasting her into oblivion
with pure, raw power as she and everything
else with her evaporate into nothingness.
Nanachi, she then weeps for her best friend,
causing Reg to weep as well.
He did it, but it's not all bad news, as Riko
finally regains consciousness
and asks for Nanachi to come with Riko
and Reg to find her mom.
And now, with nothing holding Nanachi back
and Riko fully healed, the gang heads off
further into the abyss to find Riko's mother
the cause behind Raikes creation,
and to reveal some answers
as to the creation of the Abyss itself.
And if you want to figure out the truth
about your robotself
don't forget to like comment, subscribe
and check out our
How to be playlist and below
and on behalf of everyone on the team.
Griffin, the narrator. Me (Albie),The editor.
Dom the writer. Have a happy holidays,
guys. See you next year.